[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
go in here I have to see the mayor he's
in a council meeting he can't be
disturbed
I hope you manage to let me to go to me
so my so the whole council where's the
council room I want top cousin beer Oh
cousin beer oh oh my turn a meeting keep
this commotion husband Greg our cousin
beautiful this is my cousin the mayor of
claiming I'm sorry uncle it's man he
tries mr. Biddle terrible things have
happened come in here Vegard I've been
writing all night it's a disaster
I'm ruined sit down fetch brandy and
water no water no water now what is it
what is it come on speak up like that
that was under he appeared among us the
postmaster was hanged the chief of
police was let off with 200 lashes I I
was sentenced to the firing squad
luckily my own thermi the rifles they
blow up high escape I need a fresh horse
I must be off at once fresh horse for
our cousin me sit down sit down I must
go even now he may be here in your midst
Oh speak up man who the inspector
general yes he has full power from the
Emperor himself and wherever he finds
bribery and corruption there the gallows
and a firing squad go to work more what
does he look like this inspector general
who knows Himeno mystery five days he
was an artist and no one even suspected
he went heavy where saw everything and
uncovered such corruption that even I
was shocked excited don't excite how I
envy you to sit here in your clean town
and hear no horse is ready uncle Vera
they must be off all right Bagon where
will you go the way by the way anyone
have a kacheng like
farewell uncle goodbye good bike need
any money
your better claim for something huh I
have a few crowns thank you
[Music]
farewell hey I would like to take this
opportunity to tender my resignation
effective what would you do go back to
rolling pills and that sinkhole of a
chemist shop you poison that things to
be gained by rushing around blindly we
must proceed according to the system
you'll Asma clean up the square see that
all the public buildings are spotless
but patients and all the hospital beds
here today get the children back into
school start teaching them something
anything yes brother-in-law you to
deliver the mail all of it
what are you ready - no I never did yes
you did don't you remember come back
yeah I want all roads police day and
night I want a report of everyone who
said to this town in the past 24 hours
to heaven investigate all strangers well
bring your reports to me personally you
understand yes but first time we'd like
to go first you relay orders I'll get
out of here
[Music]
we're double guards this litigation
total routes to Rodney and once on the
what happened
[Music]
come with me I think I was me anything
wrong
[Music]
I shall investigate here you men go on
to the next town countrymen approach
step up step up
come close to me the greatest experience
of your life you tell your children in
the country all with your own eyes Iook
of movie tradition to princes and
crowned heads of come among you to
exhibit absolutely free of charge the
wonder of the world
unparalleled since the dawn of time are
you ready my friends here dips marvel
the treasure of the Pharaohs behold get
right out people examine observe you
there who are you
let me see a peddlers card yeah captain
Yakov Bowie an honest professional
mental previous I have testimonials from
the Emperor himself
I will never mind what about your friend
there who he
captain don't ride away they come back
come back
this exhibit welcomes any investigation
look my friend he lives you breathe it
laughs it cries it thinks watch it left
ear how much is two and two correct this
is not just an old head this is Prince
Ahmed of ancient Egypt beheaded by the
cruel Pharaoh because of his forbidden
love for a crown princess and now my
friends you asked yourself how did this
miracle survive for over 2,000 years an
excellent question
only this yak of golden elixir look how
his eyes plead with me to give him a
dose of my nixar he's fairly yearns for
his rich smooth goodness yeah yeah bring
whoa I'm a simple man my friends I do
not make extravagant claims for my
medicine
if a person is already dead for instance
there's only a slim chance that's my
medicine will do him any good but if
only a spark of life remains Jakob
golden elixir will turn it into a
roaring fire of hell
[Music]
how can ya coffee eat those poor people
why what's the matter
well this is the furniture polish she
sold yesterday come on hurry up he's
almost through no no you don't wear this
yes even the great Napoleon himself
written on the battlefield apostolates
he gives the elixir full credit for the
victory four years I have suffered
terrible digestive distress
however since taking your cups
miraculous and exerts I no longer find
it necessary to continually hold my hand
on my summer kindest personal regards
Napoleon
all cynic sir break it to the first peg
is that for what it was Hey but why do I
tell you these things my friend when
there is someone here a sufferer on whom
I've looked with compassion when he lay
of death's door unable to move a muscle
paralyzed are you aware that you're
losing your hair money have you been on
a diet are you bothered by quiet
nice - fellas you get colds a prickly
heat a burning brow and freezing feed
anything thousand jumpin toes are
falling out her running nose in here
cups do you get here cups a touch of
laryngitis parotitis has been decided
cups
horray B's here D cups or measles have
you had a diagnosis of cirrhosis by
osmosis with the mononucleosis neurosis
[Music]
have you ever been short of breath where
Chira
europe chiral no matter how bad your
condition
I have news that particular audience I
was dead yeah well pretty thick till I
saw a famous physician who hadn't seen a
patient in here he was nearsighted he
said hello young men you were possibly
the plumber I'm a humma humma humma
you have a victim a journalist and the
member mminton easy
Toby's handsome young man you have had
some diseases have I had
but I was one I had when I was two I had
when I was three I had by the time I was
four when I was six I had at seven I
developed when I was eight I got a by
the time I was nine
doctor why am I always so tired dr.
Singh his head and gave me the following
prescription Rick's gel Snippets
edy zaminhon six no twice a day since
that day I haven't been six her that
medicine didn't fix her and what was it
don't ask me
[Music]
yeah hold
[Music]
[Applause]
they will give you news this new life no
enthusiasm what is it mother
Jimmy's my husband is sick if he had
your medicine maybe he would get well
yeah right the other side did very well
here your mother left you whatever was
wrong with your husband he's now here it
is the most wonderful the most
miraculous all cure golden elixir
mother here your penance can meet that
close mother the medicine is no good
husband he means with you I know what
this would finishing off here take the
pennies in my milk it'll do much more
than the medicine the medicine is no
don't you remember me I'm the fellow
head all the diseases and everything but
there's nothing wrong with me this
medicine is a fake yes I'm a fake yeah
officer fake
this is no good I tell you mother were
cheating all the people don't you see
they wash windows with the furniture
polish all the people that pardon me
all the people back there huh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
look
I've been fish fish knockoff with him we
can have we can have something I would
put it in here the flame it's my fish
mine now I know no but I caught it I
took it when you blend a little more
about taking it less about giving you
can't come back get out oh look I'm
sorry about that poor old woman Chilean
or Padma roll blinks that payment he
turns to Pacis couldn't help it in this
life it's dog-eat-dog right fight and
scratch that's right I have everything
for yourself I'd hold on like a leech
but I do can't even pick a pocket and
her husband yes I can so to do it I'm
aggressive jack or even better than you
see that's my walk huh when did you get
it no hey in the water please a cop
don't send me away I'll do anything you
want I'll be as hard as nailed my heart
will turn the storm block off I'll steal
my own mother's teeth I'll believe it
when I see it get out what get out oh
all right I'll go right after supper and
I'm throwing you out why do you
illiterate numbskull you I'm I'm not
illiterate you're not huh all right read
that come on read it read it read it
read it
yes read it who can read on an empty
stomach I didn't breather then I'll give
you a supper oh you will
oh well that's different it says oh this
is very interesting
your handwriting shows definite
character it shows your generous
wouldn't refuse some food to a hungry
man
good really really it says there dear
sir if I have to whom it may concern
that's right I was testing you you were
testing me whom have the best personal
regards in the polling see there you are
I dare well maybe I can't read or write
but I'm not illiterate you're nothing
just a meal storm a little fun
[Music]
whom it may concern what it's similar
way to start it
[Music]
[Music]
whom it may concern
[Music]
[Music]
the seller loves to see he when the wind
blows pair theory blocks the desert and
the sand which is there the vomit
sandwiches go get it
so just the bottom of the barrel
what do you want okay yeah I thought
perhaps you men wouldn't mind sharing
her thin little bit food with it on your
way [ __ ] we hardly got enough for
ourselves
come on get on your way well you just
gave a little piece to the dog the dog
does something praise food
oh what'd I tell you go on go away
[Music]
Loney
if I could just have a little peace step
right on my that I don't come in roll
over
can you do that isn't it good
can you do that have a little peace go
away can you do that roll over
let's see you do it once hurry up good
lie down lie down wait a minute wait a
minute I bet he can run faster and you
can
[Music]
no thanks out oh you won it fair and
square
bargain Zoomer
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
any good
but would you mind if I just taste a few
I haven't anything to eat in a couple of
days
and I'd appreciate it I thank you very
much oh now please go back I caught you
you thief who who me
overdue you've got the wrong man yes and
horse followed me ask if I'm innocent
[Music]
Kizzy Moore is it is he kind of a gift
that gives you conical eye music you can
always tell by the strawberry of Montana
never mind the hospital have you cleaned
it up oh you can eat off the floors we
put sheets on the bed and we got the
goats out of surgery
I put charts on the foot of each
patient's bed indicating the nature of
their illness good now at least they'll
know what they died from all right well
I have patrolled all the roads leading
to and from Rodney sholden unless the
Inspector General disguises himself as a
burden decides to fly into the city
he'll never get past me good and the
jail but I have had you last fitted to
all ourselves burnt the rubbish I even
have a prisoner good who is he
oh I don't know just a [ __ ] I have
preeminence it e-square he was trying to
make off with a horse and wagon the one
we were loading was silver my Sylvan my
valuables well yes but I got him before
he who is he where did he come from oh I
don't know why I never saw him before
he's just a common [ __ ]
Justin rags
[Music]
we need did you search him question him
well it was so near lunchtime and he was
he was just a common tram the
inspector-general all that's ridiculous
why not
in fact spooky first appeared as the
primary cheerleader infirmity he was
disguised as a peddler and here what
about her [ __ ]
two women my court lady the way and I
noted with many was to ship out of town
mister
of course the evidence he needed now he
knows I would like to take this
opportunity to tender my recipe
might a loss
[Music]
want some water water I want some food
I'm sorry
the prisoners are fed promptly at 3
o'clock well I guess I can hold out till
then Wednesday and Saturday Wednesday
but today is Thursday but this time I
haven't eaten two days what kind of a
jail is this where they won't even give
a man a crust of bread all I want this
is a nice jail
really it is we've had some wonderful
hangings here oh it's very nice what's
wonderful about that hanging oh you
should see the ceremony and the last
meal
the last meal okay can you order
anything you like anything
the town of brodny may have its faults
but they certainly do it like when they
hang a man they do hmm the mayor and all
the commissioners come dressed in the
finest clothes and the town man
assembles at the door of the jail such
beautiful music and they play the
prisoner right up to the gallows mm-hmm
I never forget one hanging we had a few
years ago well what's that what's what
what's that music
it might
[Music]
what were you arrested for nothing I'm
innocent
follow me all right commissioners in
everybody and they brought the band to
the bank who who they're gonna hang we
don't need one prisoner here oh well if
he doesn't finish his last me in this
Jail don't try no justice hi
I will report to the Emperor all right
there's the crooked village business III
don't you anybody come near me don't you
come near me if any of you come if you
can put to any any inconvenience I
assure you my colleagues and myself are
extremely distressed oh it is a small
community
not big Shore powerful his mother
but citizens or travelers be they humble
or exalted to the highest degree of
nobility with a vagrants or Inspector
General's reported by the emperor in our
village they find courtesy honor and
strict adherence to the principles of
justice lend us your excellency and we
were away
[Music]
believe me your highness I understand
and value your desire to remain
incognito permit me to compliment you on
your amazing disguise its most
convincing in a corrupt city with
dishonest officials as such a strategy
would be most effective but here we are
fair than it arad me we thank you to
accept our hospitality why don't we
discuss the entire situation at dinner
yeah yeah let's go to my house
tell my wife we have an honored guest
tell her I want a feast a banquet your
excellency how can we talk these sordid
surroundings at my home dinner would be
just about been a roast a turkey several
kinds of gain a rack of lamb and
magnificent pot roast and you'll
probably want a change of clothes I
think some suitable clothing for his
excellence where will I get the clothing
your uniform take it off no now your
excellency yes yes our chief of police
regrets his mistake he would be
delighted to have you wear his uniform
until your luggage arrived
Kovacs will be honored but he's tall
isn't he I know he is
is he going to stay long I hope not
he'll what's taking you so long hurry
that I can't get it if it's too tight
too tight indeed I wonder if the
Inspector General will think it's too
tight tell me did you notice the color
of his eyes no honey brown black eyes
yes
well what are you standing at stupid
I'll get busy at the table and you too
when you serve see that your hands are
clean and you Bella you'll remove the
dishes when I ring and you let us last
you bring on the fresh course and move
quickly and see that you don't spill
anything on our guests did you hear me
what did I say I take a bullet punch
when when you ring the bell all right
believe that you have something why not
do anything else we can to make yourself
useful combo what are the clean aprons
did he say anything about Paris
wellbutrin past oh yes that dress was
too tight so tight and made our eyes pop
out
[Music]
it's my humble home your excellency
it isn't large but I have only a small
pittance of a salary please
[Music]
and this is my wife Maria the
inspector-general enjoy Clinton may
others be having pleasure welcome your
hands ready and your sword my
translation today
I must get rid of him I can credit your
brand
anything just stopping your spanking did
you get the glasses a toast your
excellency there's something to prepare
your palate agency I'll see that the
dinner didn't Oh
a toast to his Excellency
Randy quickly come on briefly
quickly more brandy Villa now your
excellency how charming it is for us out
may I present mrs. Purvis your
excellency she's the wife of our tax
collector and and chemist and here we
are correctly see a little more wine
and a toast to His Majesty the Emperor
[Music]
and this is his twin brother gimmick
they're in charge of our postal
department at the inspector general
Isaac I'm Madison he's giving oh it's
very easy to tell by the strawberry
mother some other time but one more
repetitive just before dinner dinner is
served
ah dinner is served you one last big
nourishment a toast
here's to the righteous here's to the
younger
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I wouldn't think of Switzerland
I have primitive prayer in bar burger
huh
did you ever run across your uniform is
beautiful my husband had one just like
you're not disappointed in the simple
fare we serve here ladies and gentlemen
hi I would like to propose a toast to
the Paris City in all the lengths to the
home of courage integrity and honesty to
brand a proper kind of dinner I don't
because your excellency would have found
it comparable to the sumptuous table
they said at the Emperor's Palace cause
I do is give him a little more time you
know Maria if his Excellency's glass is
empty
perhaps you'll tell me about your life
in Vienna just the next day I you clumsy
gosh oh it was nothing just merely an
accident
I always feel why not my steward oh it
was procedure on me hitter with my
Easter your water there's very good for
the world just as she didn't mean just
an accident that's nothing at all right
she really didn't
don't clip bring on the meat god please
definitely they laugh let me cut it I
heard
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
something wrong your item zero try this
your excellency I always carry it with
me it'll cure anything
[Music]
good morning your excellency and she's
like nothing else before a breakfast how
did I get here we carried you up after
dinner your excellency we undressed you
we and you were in a very playful mood
your excellency what a naughty Inspector
General what Maria all right all right
good morning your excellency may I
express the hope that you spent a
comfortable night Oh what what time is
it it's just past 9:00 but you've ample
time for a substantial breakfast before
you start your tour of inspection
inspection yes our program is 11:00 a.m.
reception at the Town Hall inspection of
the guard of honor and the band concert
and at 11:30 afraid to the jails at
12:15 public hanging oh hey followed by
lunch this this hanging it isn't anyone
I know is it oh it's just some rascal
out or night police arrested the road
was impersonating a police officer
impersonating her yes he made off with a
sack of apples from a local fruit
merchant it is impersonating and after
her hanging is much too good for him
of course now I realize your excellency
wants to continue his journey as soon as
possible yes I must I must go
immediately
I have no no receptions no your
excellency I'm brokenhearted I was
looking for you miss taking our little
video yesterday so wonderful village -
village I've ever seen but I'd be kind
enough to say so in your official report
yes yes of course but I must get dressed
yes yes of course I'll assemble the
villagers and the band to speed his
Excellency on his way where are my
clothes clothes comment new uniform
well it's barely saying I was been
having it clean well in the fresh
uniform for this actually you should
where will I get one for his Excellency
yours will do this is brand new this
wouldn't fit is excellency dizzy take
care of this s3 Taylor's your exams we
can rectify that what is thankful to see
in a half an hour well you won't happen
to be quite right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
sky sky sky
[Music]
this guy
even in the short time you've been here
you've captured the hearts of our people
what a pity you have to leave well well
I I thought I might be coming back again
soon no no don't don't change your plans
on our account quick his Excellency's
horse and hit the Inspector General's
horse
[Music]
send the horse back and so on and I keep
in the back here we should help his
Excellency come out great sorrows with
them Jocko exalted one do not be angry
with your devoted servant I've hunted
for you everywhere Oh forgive me great
master forgive me but no mercy on your
unworthy servant forgive me you
numbskull or I'll break you in half
we'll be generous Manifesto
I am the lowly servant of his great love
the inspector general due to my
negligence we were separated on the road
I was just leaving
oh I must speak to you first Master the
Emperor sent two confidential
instructions a secret message please but
he was just leaving the inspector
general will decide that for himself
Yakko why did you stop me I had a chance
to get away now that meeting why are you
idiot why should they hang the inspector
general ranking on a stage they made the
whole town at your feet I don't want the
town I've got everything I want I just
want to gather here you've got
everything you want what have you got I
didn't let anything step too much and
you've gotta fight it scratch stealing
take doggy dog see boom three spoon and
these fat thieves are loaded with gold
or choco if you don't understand we can
sell the spoons buying a wagon leave
this town all right go on run away I was
right in the first place you haven't got
an honest bone in your body Thomas yeah
I don't understand only a few days ago
you kicked me out because you said I
wasn't a good thing I picked you out yes
I am I hop into a little bit more I'm
from even company and this is I guess so
once in your miserable life you have a
chance really to do some good at such a
soft know what happens you want to run
like a rabbit to save your own scabby
skin never I thought other people in the
village nothing but selfishness wait a
minute on out of this village
George you want misery exists here the
mayor his official text the very life
out of this town and not content with
that
they steal thirty five thousand crowns
they collected from the little to
from their parents to buy a pipe organ
for the church then they Trump up a
cock-and-bull story that the organ was
destroyed
but I know that they sold it another
time know now by tonight we can make
them pay 35,000 per house for protection
then I buy back the organ you present to
the town and we expose these Rascals may
I become a wandering gypsy if I'm not
telling the truth
but you are the one in jibt that proves
I'm telling the truth not the work
Georgie the most important thing is that
you make them understand that you know
how crooked they are they'll shower you
with gold Hey
35,000 clowns Yoko you think they'll
give it to me just like this they'll
give you more never fails it's even
easier when you're an inspector general
but I don't know how to be an inspector
general well that's very simple you have
to behave like one but how how why what
don't bother me with silly technicality
you're the inspector general a big
strong firm
[Music]
gentlemen I've good news for you the
Inspector General has decided to remain
indefinitely he demands an inspection of
the financial affairs of Rodney and it
will meet with you at the town hall of
two o'clock
[Music]
the big be strong be firm says Yakov but
if it doesn't work whose neck will they
turn will they not hope not Yakov be an
inspector general what does an inspector
general do inspect general no an
inspector general general inspects that
is they expect him to inspect generally
if they're expecting an inspector
general but an exceptionally generous
inspector general who made an exception
and had no inspection would cause
suspicion which in my condition I
couldn't accept thank you
however if people not suspecting now
accept without detecting an imposter
who's not posted as a pedigreed
inspector could this palpable imposter
say a gypsy or a custom could he
possibly get past them by as master in
two words
unlikely
[Music]
so it is not a question of to flee or
not to flee but to be or not to be and
it's for should I be arrogant
should I be elegant should I be spa
all roaring Russian huzzah or bury
British Empire or like the KGB enemies
who already it's a cheese while he says
no thank you please be smart
I must examine every society the long
the narrow the white of me the dr. J if
I value my anatomy the skinny and the
feta me how shall I start to play the
paw
[Music]
should I be arrogant up pop your knees
stop licking my boots elegant
a LOM lemon ice cream cream a triple G
never touch it or smart if they don't
know but you should know they will know
but you would know elegant
smart if you sit here and it's not so so
much so if you talk to them you certify
you only waste your breathe laugh at
them ha ha ha ha they're all you party
beneath oh can you show you read no runs
laugh and you saw your gentlemen if you
will just step aside for one moment I
should be very happy to talk to this
unfortunate a rich thing the course of
action you should act on that actually
planned is a Smasher a lot of thought I
put in it
if you casually cover up your mouth with
your help you will never put your foot
in it gentlemen please
[Music]
Hey
[Music]
[Music]
we'll see
you're so pleased with yourself you
don't care about me
[Music]
[Laughter]
things are not as bad as they look gypsy
born
[Music]
they are a much of war
I remember the tear in the eye is war -
in the booth
yes
[Music]
elegance elegance elegance with you I
agree or three of me you need no longer
linger
I'll give him the fist please give him
the risk given the thing
[Music]
[Music]
for the town-ho
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
everything
[Music]
[Music]
just a moment what was that I was like
[Music]
how do you account for this well well
well
there were no taxes that day excellency
no put your official signature to the
book yeah what is it it's their very
best we have your excellency if we're
not a very rich community
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
I think I'd better enough sign this
until I've you can examine the books
more closely at the house your
excellency is next once the idea we
shall see what we shall see I saw was
this Mason show The Fat Gypsy was
selling this stuff and his partner hit
on a plate who is that
that's his Excellency Inspector General
[Music]
three and one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten ready and
one two three nine ten ready and one two
one two one two one two one two one two
[Music]
even right place Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah cough I can not stay any longer
[Music]
oh this is the kitchen isn't it well you
go right ahead I'm mmm just inspecting
I'm just fine uh tell me is there
another way out oh oh us out well you're
not leaving you're excellent
Oh I have to I can't stay another minute
that there's another town I have to
inspect now right now people are waiting
I how do I get out I can't believe it
you can't believe what can't believe I
have another town to inspect well of
course I do your highness well please
don't be angry what wasn't angry I you
were so kind last night I thought you
would stay and it gave me new home but
the whole village is looking to you for
help yes well I thought perhaps on my
way back I well your excellency it's
that plundering and misery it's terrible
but you should see this out of town it's
it's they need me very badly a people
are waiting receptions and a feisty
fine I really mustn't disappoint them I
and well I'd better be going
I'm I'm sorry it won't be more friendly
friendly why should I be friendly I
don't care if I hang four I'm gonna say
what I think you're as bad as the rest
of them worse because you have the power
to do good and you run away
I'll stay I can get the organ back it
didn't burn I know where it is well then
you do care about the people of course I
do well the whole town will be so happy
I want you to be happy loser why don't
count your excellency I'm just a kitchen
Maiden I'll always be what that's no way
to look at life things can change
overnight after all I wasn't born an
inspector-general it just happened come
on smile
[Music]
and look for the gold in a rainbow you
will find happy time you'll hear at you
that lives in the heart of a bluebird
and you'll find a baton
those things may look there
is not in vain for men do you find
rainbow only after rain
so with Shanda moon and some day it may
be tomorrow you will suddenly hear
[Music]
and you'll find your happy happy times
[Music]
everybody oh yeah just look what I found
in the Rodney library Frankie's new
almanac of the Emperor's official staff
and Empress official stamp yes with
histories of their families and
portraits by celebrated ah ho ho the
portraits are very bad they're very bad
you wouldn't recognize the one of me oh
it's only women was vena fat they
thought no no I thought to see how bad
they make you look you know you never
even told me your name how soon
recognize you then attendant all about
you your beautiful wife and lovely
children
oh I have no wife none of my time I had
wise my father didn't like wives I mean
my mother didn't like my father's wife
may I have it
this looks rather like you but older of
course it's a relative of yours oh yes
it's my father your father
madam qunari one seconds into kanabi age
46 mother of 12 boys oh that was a
disguise my father was a spy in the war
and he always used to disguise himself
as my mother mother no no my mother I
was 19 before I could tell him apart
Nobby is that your family name yes
powerful snobby fossil oh what an
unusual name the morning breezes
rustling through the leaves and the
willow what does it mean
Oh hive had this some kind of soup I
think it yes where were you born
oh well I let me have the book now what
about
some some some like when we're all over
now perhaps tonight oh I won't hear
everything powerful you don't know how I
yearn to live what it means to be
married to a man who doesn't understand
me he's a peasant of course uncultured
pig man yes I was forced to marry him oh
I'm an attractive woman am I not yes in
the first room of my youth am I not yes
very desirable am I not yes but could a
man wish from a lovely intelligent
responsive woman and I am no ha ha you
say the most beautiful thing ever what I
really must be going
I'm saying you will help me Father won't
you promise yes I promise when we get to
Paris I won't be a burden to you I swear
forgive me may I have a word with your
excellency what do you want I throw
myself on your mercy please your
excellency for the sake of my family Oh
what is it what have you done the text
records it wasn't my idea to falsify
them the mayor my own uncle and to linky
all things a burden for you
I admit I take bribes but what kind of
bribes puppy dogs that's all just no
they don't
yeah it kind of okay I like to happen
your excellent forgive me yes all 60 of
them and here here's just a little gift
to share your excellency
who is it it is I alecky superintendent
of the school oh you mustn't find me at
all it's just a members
[Music]
come in your excellency if I might have
a moment of your time I have something
that might interest you look well you
see I have the best interest of the
state if I don't I would never tell you
this you understand yes well I can't
come to the point a key I have to like a
like a sometimes a man must decide
between duty and friends and I feel it
is my duty to advise you of the vice and
corruption in the city abroad me this
isn't much but if you will just accept
it is alone if you don't kiss against me
if you should find me here come in come
in I'm a poor man your excellency
please accept offers that's all I had
the temptation was too strong the other
stole more than I did they did who is
that oh come with me we gotta hide in
the closet here
Oh inspector general head lesson thing I
want to thank you that must be you do my
uniform looks very nice on you thank you
well I'm having my maiden black with
silver across here what is it covet oh I
guess I might as well make a clean
breast of it won't you a sit down yes
thank you you see it wasn't for me for
my wife my wife is not a contented woman
she wants clothing and money and jewels
all kind of my family but I give my six
kids to get rid of my way so there's
only a thousand crowns a thousand proud
yeah
if you'll just give me a chance to tell
the jokes won't you sit down
[Music]
[Music]
come in
[Music]
[Music]
what no you were resting your excellent
oh I always raised the doctor says it's
good for my liver
well maybe I better come back oh it's
all right
what is it you want I just wanted to
make a confession I'll take it well
fella comes I'm as guilty as the rest of
them but I oh I mustn't be filed
[Music]
can I come in
you don't have to put our yeah the
message come from the Emperor
what go go downstairs and see if my
luggage has arrived
what's the matter with you what's the
weather outside like look I don't want
people hiding in it I think you all know
that the council members that came with
bribes
arrives right money money money
[Music]
where is it
why come in your next please may I speak
to you for a moment
yes of course privately
[Music]
[Music]
today all a mayor and you to meet the
Chief of Police yes his highness cannot
tolerate this Alice no then why did he
accept the bribes a few measly crowns
his Excellency has many private
charities I can assure you another penny
of that money will ever find the screen
to the pockets of the inspector general
now that what do you want us to do it's
possible a be a possibility mind you
that few substantial contributions from
you might how much shall we say a
hundred thousand crowns hundred thousand
crowns I'll be a pauper very well keep
your money you can jingle it in your
pockets all the way up the steps to the
gallows he wouldn't do anything like
that he wouldn't he has but he might be
inclined to show leniency if he can
realize the charitable dream of his life
I must need an addition to the cathedral
he built in Vienna a new church organ a
fireproof
and happy he knows you know
[Music]
we can get rid of him without leaving a
trace and none of us will be involved
who do it
the woodchopper you do as I tell him he
has to I can get him tonight during the
reception when always confusion the
noise but if something goes wrong
nothing will go wrong are you sure yes
after midnight as soon as everyone's
head i need to drink one of us will get
him into the barn where they tell of
woodchoppers waiting he would his
project good
[Music]
all right what are you doing all right
you think I want to steal it I want to
count it well I've already counted you
can't count well it's very heavy them
must be enough money here to buy back
the organs all right give it to me I'll
go get the organ oh no not without me
look you can't leave here they need you
for the reception well then we'll go
after the reception look yeah there's an
old Hungarian proverb trust everybody
but keep the organ money in sight come
in
[Music]
[Music]
what is that oh that's just a letter
Kanaka that whole love letter I score
with love letter for you let me see an
old Yakov oh let me know II have it yeah
never mind
no not let me know yeah scoff you might
tear
well could you read it for me
[Music]
Oh Georgie you're such a lucky guy what
is it I have a beautiful girl like that
fall in love with you want read the
Tommyknockers
please my dearest darling inspector
general from the moment I first saw you
I knew you were the one at night a dream
of your manly figure and your handsome
gentle features drive me mad with
passionate love the sound of your voice
thrills me beyond words and if I cannot
have you for my very own
I must surely die is there any more does
she say anything else yes there PS
please meet me in the barn at midnight
please meet me Devon
[Music]
yeah coffee what is PSB um yes
please sweetheart
please
[Music]
[Music]
I have a carriage waiting father there's
a carriage and I can't help at all
I need to stay black to the dance well
yeah
[Music]
I have the money is he sending as a
report Oh tell him I'll deliver to him
tonight
good we can't settle a never in here
where would you suggest outside in the
barn
@midnight @midnight he'll be there
[Music]
I'm gonna get ready I'll see you later
[Music]
I got your note feel wonderful the bar
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
turn away and parental French Christine
Conrad lifelong friend of his Excellency
the inspector general we've been friends
for many many years
announce me in one shot ready yes tell
hmm Oh young man probably the eyes olive
kernel yes yes I was snow blinded in the
Alps of the Italian campaign with His
Majesty the Emperor the Emperor long
life disappear Majesty the Emperor Oh
oh you idiot where are oh there you are
you blithering idiot now where are my
glasses my glasses I will be careful
there's no way I don't step on them oh
look oh you still be cold I'll have to
go and get another pair I don't know
what you just did right hold on your
excellency
ladies and gentlemen I have the honor to
announce the unexpected arrival of
Colonel Franz gastein of the Emperor's
Royal Guards comrade-in-arms and
lifelong friend of his Excellency the
inspector general
the perilous fight deicide doesn't have
them important to break his glasses
imagine he broke his glass layer Ono
panel lay upon the wrong man this is the
Inspector General oh of course how
stupid of me yes the Inspector General
is really a much shorter man
Leopold this is indeed a joy a joy oh I
noticed that you've you shaved your
moustache ma oh yeah just a tickle not
me that it's alright it's alright it
makes you look much younger and your
voice it seemed to sound much more
useful not always have parents are my
friends this is the man who's
single-handed routed an entire regiment
of Italians at the Battle of Levin Gretl
and then he pushed their own cannon into
position and fired at the retreating
enemy do you remember that my boys
nothing hostile it's too much oh you
didn't do much he just drove into a
raging river and rescued four wounded
soldiers and then on the way he cut down
10 Spaniards with his with his saber
lose the morale was very low but with
this magnificent courage he plunged into
the fray and he led his men with a song
the victory song of the 94th regiment
onward onward never looking back
army division how does it go Leopold yes
he doesn't like to be reminded of that
magic day but he might be persuaded to
sing something lighter more gay okay
Oh splendid splendid and I can get my
glasses from here oh no sir no sir why
don't you sing something now and another
colonel senior in Brazil before he gets
his dress
could I borrow your drink to the song
please and now and now I for my friend
and comrade in arms I'd I'd like to do a
gypsy mmm gypsy drinking song my wine is
plenty no nobody's family for why it's
deadly poison oh you did myself love
your wife
for years I've misjudged 2004 oh no no
no it was for me for you yes I couldn't
stand it any longer I even wrote a
confession
[Music]
whisking through the Whispering Woods
and a while the Roman upon me with a
young catcher can I get Cedric an
eccentric Cydonia life the gypsy gypsy
and careless and my peepee - remember
singable babe with a woman in his hand
over tipsy he said and this is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] took advice and drink - hello -
the open drink with my nose and so but
first we sing how can you sing gypsy
song with a gypsy curse so ladies and
gentlemen I will ask you for a little
favor you help me we'll have a little
chorus will sound beautiful wonderful I
will give you a little beat you make for
me zoom all right please everybody so
it's very nice but we get a little
sharper you know more in the mask in the
Ephraim aha please all right so many
nice now short that I like I like once
more please
so very pretty this group here I will
make for you stock stock please
everybody understand stock stock all
right
very nice all right but me let us enjoy
them please small stock
very nice it's so pretty low
I'll be with you in two minutes now this
little crop here I'd like you to make a
little favour and me all the little tiny
Pussycats those sweet gentle little
faces make for me hahaha this way all
right please everybody and applaud now
Christmas past we have said everybody
listen once you get pissed very pretty I
love you to pieces please
Oh such an eternal
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you want something to drink maybe No
thank you excellence and so we bring but
first we play
[Music]
[Music]
pardon me I slipped my ball my thing is
neither isn't
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and for me what helps to be down
[Music]
on me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and so we dream to everything we love to
everyone we admire to the girl who set
your heart alone
and set your heart
and the soul
I like
[Music]
Oh would you excuse me ladies I have
something no I beg your enjoying the eat
yes I very much I really have to
[Music]
Lisa Lisa are you clumsy ox what's the
matter with you you're crazy you know
you could have killed me with that why
do you have to work so late at night
anyway whatever you have to chop can
wait till morning can it found out
number one a bit who want I've gotta
meet somebody here who want a bit Julia
Specter general yeah that doesn't mean I
can't meet anybody here does it no hmm
you don't believe it do you
[Music]
don't go near the barn they're going to
kill you when only two hours ago she
[Music]
would you reread Derek getting please
just don't go near the barn they are
going to give you Yakko Yakko my best
friend
[Music]
wait remastered I master
[Music]
well how did it you'll know how now
gentlemen let's get down to business
for a price I'll get rid of the evidence
the money
I don't think I want any supper No
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Yakko what are you doing yeah where you
going
[Music]
[Music]
your best friend
[Music]
well we always get the old
inspector general Baili inspector
general
what must have been an echo yeah
[Music]
announcing the emissary of the Apple our
general Leopold Nicolai Tarantino his
Excellency the Inspector General
[Music]
he took bribes he's been called my wine
he yelled out the windows he even made
love to my wife how come how could I
doubt that he was an inspector general I
mean he gave us no chance to think of
deception your majesty I mean your
excellency isn't that right easy and as
a keys keys like you can always tell by
the strawberry mark on my leg what is
your biggest I music yes as it is
excuse me action scene first of all
mayor I want that train send out every
man available yes meanwhile I will write
out an order for his execution people
hang today I promise you that
[Music]
it isn't here is the organ the one that
was stolen but we we give the money we
had and then now it's back I'll see you
in a minute here
take the organs of the church I'll be
back in a minute
[Music]
I'm glad I found all you gentlemen
together this town is going to be
cleaned up from know about the inspector
general yes mr. mayor I'd like you all
to know that the corruption in this city
is at an end
I want to complete an honest report from
you and a complete report of your tax
records I want to report from you in the
morning who is this man tell him to get
out this is official business
mr. mayor in the name of the Emperor I
call upon you to produce all the text
records and books of this village
immediately you will permit me to
interrupt let me show you this
communication which has just arrived
[Music]
silly girl and out of business
I really bank upon this is the inspector
general how do you do we must have a
long talk together sometime I want to
look at all these people the books means
we regret this you taste village how
dare you have dirty hands off me or miss
McGuffin today about the Emperor will
tear this stinking village down over
your ears you thieving lard bucket heads
we're all here like marbles yours first
and then this flea-ridden sack of
nothing you holiest we didn't say this
general you only make me laugh the great
emperor wouldn't appoint a thing like
this to a post of such importance this
is your Inspector General here is
carriage his mana is bearing gentlemen
take your choice I don't know what to
think you don't have to think if this
men to the inspectors Herald anyway is
credentials Oh where's yours
show them your excellency they have a
right to see come on children Oh your
credentials show them oh look Raju them
Hey
here they are Hey all right correct
I I would like to take this opportunity
to tender my resignation if I'm sorry
your excellency it was honest mistake
the impostor will hang this is prepaid
for an intimacy would be so good as to
write out the death warrant and it did
just one minute ordinary arrest Batman
I'm warning you I'm warning all of them
this will be reported to the Emperor
back him up I can't do it why not oh one
thing I can't write oh I can't read
either and even if I could write I
couldn't sign this death line I'm I'm
not the inspector general oh he's just
soft-hearted here outside and do it yeah
all right you can it's all over I
couldn't sign this that man is
completely innocent I hang I only did it
so I could get the money to buy the
organ back i [ __ ] them up again put them
in Chains I never the gals Oh your
excellency I'm so sorry but nothing like
this has ever happened only because I
you shouldn't they will go to the
gallows your excellency the gallows will
wait it's turn but not now but your
excellency be this man will not hang
huh first honest man I've met since I
left Budapest whatever you say
[Music]
but my my chain of office your next will
put something else around your name
thank you your excellency
whaddaya music what'd you say big band
music with many music oh why couldn't
take this your excellency I I can't even
read or write I I have no education and
what you have is much better
please directions like presenters my
medal
[Music]
citizens of Bradley I have the honor to
present to you your new mayor
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this guy
you